[Musique]
pas de souvenirs d'enfance des odeurs
les villes
paysages de départ acyclique t jet pack
passé je pas d'avenir
j'ai l'instant présent très fort
violemment
je crois qu'il faut pouvoir et savoir
refaire sa vie à chaque matin c'est très
important
il faut savoir aussi refaire l'amour à
chaque matin je veux dire par là que se
reconquérir
je ne connais pas de joie plus grande
que celle de données de se sacrifier de
se dépouiller pour ceux que l'on aime ou
pour ceux que l'on ne connaît pas
quelque part vraiment je ne connais pas
de joie plus grande
en fait je pense que tout est amour de
ma religion c'est l'amour si je n'avais
pas chanté sans doute j'aurais été bonne
soeur ou [ __ ] je crois qu'il faut se
brûler il faut vivre jusqu'à la
déchirure passionnément
[Musique]